تحرك فوق حوريات البحر
وقابل حورية البحر مايك، أنا مندهش جدًا مما
يثير اهتمام الغواص مايك بيلي هو
العثور على الأشياء التي يفقدها الناس تحت الماء في
بحيرات كاليفورنيا، آخر مهمة مستحيلة له هي
العثور على خاتم زفاف جيني بولز بينما
كنت أسبح، لقد فقدت خاتم زواجي على بعد
47 قدمًا من البحر.  المياه في بحيرة باس بكاليفورنيا،
مياه باردة متجمدة، موكي مع سحب من
الطمي ورؤية شبه معدومة، مسلحًا بمصباح يدوي
وكاشف معادن،
بحث مايك بشكل أعمى مما أعطى لنفسه
فرصة بنسبة 2 بالمائة للنجاح، ومع ذلك
كان
مايك متحمسًا جدًا للعثور على
التسعة آلاف.  خاتم بخمسمائة دولار
كان يتأوه حرفيًا بسرور
عندما ظهر على السطح أما بالنسبة
لجيني
الآن، فإن مايك لا يتقاضى رسومًا، لقد أصرّت جيني
على منحه إكرامية 200 دولار، لقد كنت
متحمسًا أكثر مما كانت عليه أعتقد عندما
وجدته، لقد حصلت على  الكثير من الناس يكونون
مثل الصراخ تحت الماء
كثيرًا أو مثل أن كلماتك
مزعجة نوعًا ما، أشعر أنني لا أستطيع مساعدتها، أشعر بسعادة
غامرة عندما أجد شيئًا ما،
كما لو كان يجب أن أذهب إلى مكان ما، يكون مايك
متحمسًا عندما يفعل ذلك.  يجد زوجًا من
النظارات الشمسية مفتوحًا أكثر أو هاتفًا أو
عجلة من سيارة Ford Model T موديل 1908
يحتفظ بها في ما يسميه غرفة كنزه الأكثر غرابة، يجد
أنه
دمية إنقاذ لمدة
ثانيتين أو ثلاث ثوانٍ تقريبًا، اعتقدت أنها كانت
حقيقية  الجسد وكان ذلك مرعبًا للغاية
[موسيقى]
حسنًا في الواقع أخبر بارك رينجرز في بحيرة
ناتوما مايك ما هو أن
دمية الإنقاذ تيمي فقدت أثناء
التدريب ولكن من حورية البحر مايك يستعيد
ما يسقط يرفع معنوياته
تحقق من ذلك
جيني موس سي إن إن
نيويورك